they came for an adventure in the
remotest place on earth
they got Q's carnage and tragedy the man
who filmed this long breathless crawl to
the top of Everest turned back fearing
for his life it has become a death race
there because there was massive traffic
jam and people are pushing themselves
we're not even capable of doing it they
do it they try to summit and they
instead of summiting they kill
themselves and it's turned into a bad
thing and I think people should really
look into it the reason for the sneaking
lines of Mountaineers at the top of the
world a record number of permits and a
narrow window of good weather the delays
made the already extreme conditions
worse according to this climber who has
the scars to prove it I had to wait a
while for the traffic to decrease so we
could go because of that I was very cold
and I was protecting myself if there was
no traffic that maybe this frostbite
would not have happened
Robin Fisher is one of 11 people to have
died this season he's shot this video
describing the conditions as he set out
for the summit but it is at the Death
Zone
near the Hillary step where the
congestion is most dangerous tourism
officials have promised to implement
safety barriers but no limits the number
of climbers who come to our mountains is
actually quite low compared to other
countries
we're not going to fix or limit the
number of climbers we're trying to get
more tourists and climbers to come to
Nepal by giving them better facilities
and safety we want to encourage them to
come for both pleasure and fame as
cleanup operations get underway on
Everest it's not just rubbish they're
collecting for more bodies were plucked
off the mountain another reminder that
the pursuit of pleasure and Fame can
come at the
Grievous price